I promise this is not turning into a
reaction channel hey wassup guys my name
is Shannon and today we are going to be
talking about the PlayStation 5
specifically watching and reacting to
the PlayStation 5 technical details deep
dive video by Mike's Ernie
so last week I put up my reaction to the
new Unreal Engine 5 demo and so many of
you requested that I make a reaction to
the PlayStation 5 video and specifically
this mark Sony deep dive video now
unlike the Unreal Engine 5 video I have
not seen a single second of this video
whatsoever I have no idea what it's
about you mean is about the PS 5 so far
the other thing I know is that is called
the road to PS 5 it's 52 minutes and 44
seconds long which is very long so we'll
see what happens here we might end up
splitting this into like multiple parts
or I might end up skipping through this
depending how much is here I don't know
we'll see what happens I don't know how
to react to this video how to deal with
it because I haven't seen it yet and
that will be a great joy to the number
of you who suggested that I should
retitle my video because it's not a
reaction if I've seen it before
first of all since when does the word
react mean the first time you see
something if I throw the same tennis
ball at you twice are you just not gonna
react the second time just gonna hit you
in the face anyway consider this more of
a purist reaction so let's dive in and
take a look at this video first of all
even before I hit play this has a lot of
dislikes I wonder why probably just all
of the Xbox fanboys or PC master-race
fanboys it's interesting to me because
like consoles in general seem to have so
much hate attached to them especially
from people who just you know always
maintained that pcs as superior everyone
should be gaming on PCs and I just don't
understand all this hate and obviously I
don't know why this dislike so here I
haven't watched the video yet maybe it's
complete trash but from what I've heard
it's a very good video and the stuff
that they're revealing is really really
cool so I am actually really interested
to dive in I don't think that consoles
should just be completely disregarded I
don't think that like this is this is a
complex topic and this isn't really like
sure knows thoughts on consoles but I
did just want to say that as a game
developer and as someone in the industry
making a game for a console is a
completely different experience to
making a game for a PC people don't
really consider this too much from
the actual creators perspective they
just kind of look at it from the user
and and say that oh well you know my
computer is more powerful than this
console I can make I can do this I can
do that I can customize it I can you
know why would anyone play on a console
it's just complete trash keyboard a
mouse is better all that stuff and I get
that and that's fine that's fine in fact
that the few games that I do play I too
mostly play on PC but I do want to say
that consider this from the creators
point of view if you're making a game
making it work with a computer is a
completely different experience and a
completely different set of challenges
to making it work with a console you see
computers are all different they have
completely different sets of hardware
they might be super powerful they might
be super not powerful than my face super
weak right so when someone makes a game
for a computer they need to spend a lot
of time basically degrading their game
so that it can work on a wide variety of
hardware they have to come up with all
these different tearing settings like
you need to have like a low tier and mid
tier a high tier an ultra tier you know
a huge amount of graphic settings need
to get exposed but when you're a creator
working on your piece of art which is
your game you're not working at it in
like some kind of degraded lower quality
you're working at it at the highest
quality possible because it's your
artwork it's your baby and then what
happens is you need to make sure that
you basically sacrifice the quality of
your piece of art so that people with
lower spec systems can actually play
this game and that can be really that
can be painful you know that can be
painful for a game developer whereas if
you're developing a game for a console
you can basically guarantee that the
exact same experience that you are
designing will be had by the players who
actually play your game the people who
enjoy your art are going to see your art
in the way that you made it that's
special you know that is very special
whereas with PC who knows what kind of
system they're running maybe they'll
hate the game because you can't deliver
the same kind of atmosphere because
their system just can't handle it so
anyway don't hate on consoles
hate on PC just let's just let's just
enjoy all the amazing art that people
are creating ok sorry about that let's
get back into the video let's start the
video hi
unfortunately we had to cancel the the
talk that we had planned for GDC but we
do have yes 5 and I guess not
I think what I might do with this video
cuz again it is extremely long is I
might just we'll see how it goes I don't
know what to what to - yeah I don't know
what to say yet at this point at this
point in the video but I don't really
want to skip any of it so I might just
edit out me watching it um and I only
kind of I guess include the interesting
parts better to bring that to but either
way let me know what you guys think in
the comments below because like
obviously like this is you know this is
this is made for you guys to enjoy and
if I'm just ruining everything then Knox
Ernie without further ado over to you
mark mics Ernie almost sounds like
Cherney chatter thank you Jim there'll
be lots of chances later on this year to
look at the PlayStation 5 games today I
want to talk a bit about our goals for
the PlayStation 5 hardware and how they
influenced the development of the
console I just want to say like and
again not nothing started yet but I'm
not looking at this as some kind of PC
elitist who knows that this platform is
gonna be trash compared to a computer
first of all just so that you guys are
aware that even there like in general
consoles are situated at a lower price
bracket which is which doesn't sacrifice
quality you know you can't like a 20 at
20 atti is what like $2000 or something
like that like you obviously that kind
of level of hardware cannot be in a
console because otherwise it would cost
a lot of money I do realize that but I'm
not I'm still not looking at this being
like oh it's going to be so much worse
than PC I'm actually really excited
about this and theoretically speaking
theoretically speaking this has every
chance to be better and to kind of
facilitate better games in both
graphical fidelity and in I guess
experience than a computer it has the
potential and I have not heard anything
about this platform yet I mean about
like a couple of years ago I think we
did get some back
when I worked at a we did get some specs
of the PlayStation 5 and I remember
reading a little bit through them they
were likes to be confidential and I'm
sure the loved a lot has changed since
then obviously I don't have a copy of
that and obviously I did not like I
don't remember that so we'll say that
that's all I've heard
I have not since then I have not heard
anything about the PlayStation 5 or the
new Xbox I think you all know I'm a big
believer in console generations once
every 5 or 6 or 7 years a console
arrives with substantially new
capabilities there's a lot of learning
by the game developers hopefully not too
overwhelming and soon there's games that
could never have been created before now
it used to be that as a console designer
you'd somehow Intuit what would be the
best set of capabilities for the new
console and then build it in complete
secrecy for the PlayStation consoles
that period lasted through PlayStation 3
a powerful and groundbreaking console
but also one that caused quite a lot of
heartache as it was initially difficult
to develop games for mmm-hmm so start
yeah the PlayStation 3 like those we
don't know like it had a slightly
different architecture had like cell
processors and stuff like that it just
you know it has something called an SPU
it was designed in us in a different way
where it was just not as easy to program
for as just a standard kind of like PC
like architecture and because of that
because it was kind of I guess a new
hardware architecture it took people
like some people like just did not know
how to write good quality software for
it but also just took the industry as a
whole a little bit of time to get used
to it but what's interesting is the
games that did actually leverage that
that that's that architecture properly
they ended up really excelling because
the architecture whilst unique and while
special did provide kind of difficulties
in the games industry for certain people
and certain studios if used correctly
which was a difficult thing to do then
it it really did do it fighting with
PlayStation 4 we've taken a different
approach roughly centered around three
principles the first of these is
listening to the developers which is to
say that a lot of what we put into a
console derives directly from the needs
and aspirations of the game creators we
definitely do have some ideas of our own
but at the core of our philosophy for
designing consoles is that game players
are here for the fantastic games which
is to say that game creators matter
anything we can do to make life easier
for the game creators or help them
realize their dreams we will do so
that's really important obviously
because the people making the content
are not going to be necessarily the
people making the platform it's like
when you're making a game engine you
want to listen to the people who are
using your game engine to see what
exactly you should put it to the game
engine what kind of workflows they
expect the difficulties that they're
encountering so about once every two
years I take a tour of the industry I go
to the various developers and publishers
sit down and discuss how they're doing
with the current consoles and what
they'd like to see in future consoles
this requires weeks on the road as
reaching the bulk of the game creators
involves talking to well over a hundred
people it's something like two dozen
publishers and developers and it is
incredibly valuable by the way the
feature most requested by the developers
that was an SSD which we were very happy
to put in hardware but a lot of problem
solving was required I'll be doing a
deep dive on the SSD and surrounding
systems yeah now I've heard a lot of
things about the SSD and in fact without
really knowing about the SSD have built
or the PlayStation 5 in the Unreal
Engine video I did kind of like suggest
that an SSD is probably playing a huge
role in what was able to be achieved in
that demo
I think the primarily the primary reason
why developers asked for an SSD and why
that's so important is because more more
and more of the games assets are
becoming extremely large developers are
trying to develop higher quality assets
and higher quality assets like simply
put they just they take up more data
they take up more bytes of data like
they they are bigger and because they're
bigger you can't really you have to be
very careful about what you actually
keep on the GPU Ram or you actually keep
on the CPU Ram you have to be a little
bit more specific about what it is that
we need
to actually have in our GPU memory for
immediate rendering and what we can just
not even keep in CPU RAM anymore like
like it was kind of possible with lower
resolution textures to just have the
whole texture in memory all the time but
now because of these extremely high
quality assets and because that's being
pushed further and further and you know
not to mention like open worlds and the
fact that we have just not even the
quality of each asset is higher but the
amount of assets is higher and we have
all of this kind of data to deal with
because of all of this we need to be
able to actually stream the data
straight from disk into like RAM and
then eventually put it into like GPU Ram
or something like that based on how it's
required but the point is that that's
becoming a real bottleneck because if
the disk speed is just not fast enough
for us to be able to immediately say oh
I need that asset and I need it into my
GPU Ram as soon as possible because I
need to display it on the screen like
now that's a huge limitation that's a
huge bottleneck and that was stopping a
lot of developers from being able to
just simply use larger sets of data
because well the disk just can't keep up
Pacey's obviously like recently just the
SSD space for PC with mws these days and
all that stuff they're extremely fast
and that's not so much a problem but
with consoles that was later on in this
talk that was a bit of an issue it's
also key to make a generational leave
while keeping the console sufficiently
familiar to game developers I think
about this in terms of balancing
evolution and revolution now with
Playstation one two and three the target
was a revolution each time with a brand
new feature set that was great in many
ways but time for the developers to get
up and running got longer with each
console in the past I've called this
time to triangle here's what I had for
those three consoles to be clear I'm not
talking time time to triangle is quite a
popular kind of metric about time to
make it you can mean a lot of things
game but in this case in this case he's
basically just saying that like okay
let's just say this you'd like you have
a new new platform right I have here's a
PlayStation 3 right I want you to get a
triangle in the screen like from scratch
how long is that gonna take you and
obviously like the the lower that time
to triangle is the easier it is to do
things with that platform
for example in OpenGL at time - like if
you're writing an OpenGL program
times triangle is very fast it's not
like particularly difficult to do that
especially with like legacy up in jail
or DirectX 9 for example really fast
time to triangle because everything is
fixed function everything is really
simple modern versions of OpenGL a
little bit longer and then if you look
at something like Vulcan your time to
triangle is gonna be a long time because
you have to set up everything it's gonna
be very long so that's another reason
fellow first country ambitious and it
may take them six years or so to realize
their vision what I'm talking about is
that dead time before graphics and other
aspects of game development are up and
running and trying to minimize that on
the other hand if we're trying to reduce
that dead time to 0 that means the
hardware architecture can't change at
all we're handcuffed we need to judge
for each feature what value it adds and
whether it's worth the increase in
developer time needed to support it so
with PlayStation 4 we were able to
strike a pretty good balance I really
like this guy's like talk by the way
he's like very good at presenting which
is like refreshing to see response rate
and familiarity we got required learning
back to PlayStation 1 levels with PS 5
the GPU was definitely the area we felt
the most tension between adding new
features and keeping a familiar
programming model ultimately I think
we've ended up with something under a
month of getting up to speed that feels
like we're striking about the right
balance I'll go into a bit more detail
later today about our philosophy with
the GPU and the specific feature set
that resulted from it it's also very
important for us as the hardware team to
find new dreams by which I mean
something other than CPU performance GPU
performance and the amount of RAM the
increase in graphics performance over
the past two decades has been
astonishing but there are other areas in
which we can innovate and provide
significant value to the game creators
and through them the players that's why
the SSD was very much on our list of
directions to explore regardless of what
came out of the conversations with game
developers and publishers the biggest
feature in this category is the custom
engine for audio that's today's final
topic the push for vastly and
audio and in particular 3d audio isn't
something that came out of the developer
meetings it's much more the case that we
had a dream of what might be possible
five years from now and then worked out
a number of steps we could take to set
us on that path so here again are the
three principles the first being
enabling the desires of developers to
drive the hardware design to me the SSD
really is the key to them by the way I'm
definitely gonna watch this whole video
normally five minutes in and I I'll
probably end up splitting this up into
multiple videos like in terms of my
reaction because I'm sure there's a lot
I'm gonna want to say about this but I'm
definitely watching this whole thing
it's really interesting solution and I
do want to I do want to know everything
about this visit a game changer and it
was the number one ask from developers
for PlayStation 5 as in we know it's
probably impossible but can you put an
SSD in it that was a discussion we were
also having internally it was clear that
the presence of a hard drive in every
PlayStation 4 was having a positive
impact a lot of things that would simply
have been impossible at blu-ray disc
speeds were now possible at the same
time yeah I wasn't actually even
considering disc space I was thinking
about more or less games that were quite
an install because that was a lot of
games were kind of doing that
bleuer I did yeah that's even more so
yes in 2016 when we were having these
coffee but but that's also kind of to be
expected because a lot of this stuff is
moving to a digital marketplace lots of
games while still kind of sold on
blu-ray discs and you know we're talking
about like 50 gigabytes of data there
probably if not more you know that kind
of I still feel like as the industry as
a whole obviously is is more or less
gravitating towards like streaming
services for games meaning that you can
like you can purchase like a
subscription and then you get like a
like kind of like a play I guess you get
like a set amount of games that you can
kind of use in your library and all of
that is like a digital marketplace where
you can also purchase games and a lot of
games are only distributed digitally so
it obviously makes sense that like discs
are kind of gonna be coming out of phase
and so a physical game stores and I
guess game copies right and then it's
more or less moving towards something
like Steam for PC conversations
developers were already banging up
against the limits of the hard drive and
a lot of developer time was being spent
designing around slow load speeds mm-hmm
I want to focus in on just one number
here which is how long it takes to load
a gigabyte of data from a hard drive the
difficulty being that hard drives are
neither particularly fast nor flexible
if all your data is in one block which
is frankly not very likely you can load
50 to 100 megabytes a second depending
on where the data is located on the hard
drive let's assume it's on the outer
edge which means loading a gigabyte
takes 10 seconds if you compress your
game packages you can fit more data on
the blu-ray disk and also effectively
boost your hard drive read speed by the
compression ratio we support Z Lib
decompression on PlayStation 4 that gets
you something like 50% more data on the
disk and 50% higher effective speed
unfortunately yeah so this is the thing
that people didn't really consider as
well compression right so obviously
storing raw assets is probably almost
never done especially because discs
obviously both hard drives like both
hard drive installations and like
blu-ray discs have a finite amount of
space and it's it might not be enough
everything is pretty much always
compressed now when you compress things
you're you're basically playing with
like a little bit of a trade-off here
you can trade your CPU time or your
decompression kind of time for less disk
space so in other words instead of
occupying like a hundred megabytes the
data may be this kind of texture asset
or something occupies 50 megabytes of
data however it's not ready for me to
send to the GPU immediately as is I
can't just read the data off the disk
and immediately give it to my GPU I mean
obviously GPUs have like the texture is
probably not the crater not the greatest
example because obviously there are
compression formats for textures they
actually are decoded like on the GPU at
sample time and all of that stuff so
we'll just ignore that analogy but the
point is you know you have an asset you
can't just immediately send it to the
GPU or process it on the CPU or do
whatever you need with that asset before
you decompress it
however it's less data to read so the
point is if you have a fast CPU and a
slow disk it's a lot better to kind of
compress stuff and then kind of read it
in and then have the CPU do the work on
it if you read less
dadah than it is to read double the data
and do nothing on the cpu tour because
it's already in the right format you
don't need to transform it so that's
kind of what he's talking about here
that it and he mentions ad lib as a
decompression library like zedla Zed Lib
is a fairly heavy decompression mic
library it's not for example like lz4 is
something that is a lot faster to
decompress but the file size is larger
Zed live actually compresses like quite
well it's it's fairly like the
decompression times going to be slower
but obviously in this case the disk is
is reinforcing the fact that the disk is
so slower that they're actually they're
actually using rather heavy compression
to kind of get around that gently though
it's highly likely that your data is
scattered around in various files on the
hard drive as well as sourced from
multiple locations within those files so
lots of sikhs are needed at 2 to 50 ish
milliseconds each my rule of thumb is
that the hard drive is spending
two-thirds of its time seeking and only
a third of its time actually loading
data putting all of that together a
gigabyte isn't very rough why it's so
important to keep your daughter together
doesn't matter if it's in RAM or on disk
you know 20 seconds to load from a hard
drive now a gigabyte is not much data
games are using 5 or 6 gigabytes of RAM
on PlayStation 4 so boot times and load
times can get pretty grim or to put that
differently as a player you wait for the
game to boot wait for the game to load
wait for the level to reload every time
you die and you wait for what is
euphemistically called fast travel and
all of that leads to the dream what if
we could have not just an SSD but a
blindingly fast SSD
if we could load 5 gigabytes a second
from it what would change now SSDs are
completely different from hard drives
they don't have sikhs as such if you
have a 5 gigabyte a second SSD you can
read data from a thousand different
locations in that second pretty much at
speed as for time to load a gigabyte
this is next-gen we're talking about so
memory is bigger instead we should be
asking how long to load 2 gigabytes and
the answer is about a quarter of a
second that's amazing we're talking two
orders of magnitude
meaning very roughly 100 times faster
which means at five gigabytes a second
for the SSD the potential now this is a
huge chump obviously you guys don't need
me to tell you that you can see that
from the numbers but I do want to point
out that the hard drive on the
PlayStation liked it not the best so yes
it's a huge jump and this is really good
that this is a thing now don't get me
wrong I'm not at all saying that it's
not that good it's it's brilliant but
it's even more brilliant because of how
bad it used to be was that the game
boots in a second there are no load
screens the game just fades down while
loading a half-dozen gigabytes and fades
back up again same for a reload you're
immediately back in the action after you
die and fast travel becomes so fast it's
blinking you miss it as game creators we
go from trying to distract it's gonna
happen to old tips that are displayed
during loading screen the moment gonna
know how to play this how long fast
travel is taking like those Spiderman
subway rides to being so blindingly fast
that we might even have to slow that
transition down yeah pretty cool right
but for me this is not the primary
reason to change from a hard drive to an
SSD the primary reason for an ultra-fast
SSD is that it gives the game designer
freedom what a put what he said by the
way about slowing down that reminds me
of like when I first started making
games and I was still in high school and
all of that I like my games were
obviously so simple and so dumbed down
and like that they had like no loading
straights everything was pretty much
instantaneous but I actually wanted to
have a loading screen a little progress
bar because I was like well all games
have that I want to have that as well
and so I added like some threats leaps
in there just to make the loading screen
like longer so that I could display
something and so ya can sabotage
differently with a hard drive the twenty
seconds that it takes to load a gigabyte
can sabotage the game that the developer
is trying to create exactly I think
almost all of us in the room have
experienced this maybe in different ways
say we're making an adventure game and
we have two rich environments where we
each want enough text
and models to fill memory what you can
do as long as you have a long staircase
or elevator ride or a windy corridor
where you can ditch the old assets and
then take 30 seconds or so to load the
new assets yes that's really really
common it's you're basically forcing the
player into some kind of limited area of
the map where there aren't too many
assets actually needed to interact with
or to render and then meanwhile
asynchronously
you're streaming in assets from disk and
that might take a while but that's fine
because some other threads doing that in
the background as long as the player
manages to get to where the new assets
are required in a longer time than it
takes to actually stream in the assets
onto the GPU and the CPU for interaction
rendering all that stuff then you're
fine but obviously designing your game
around that can be problematic it works
for a lot of games like there's you know
that they're just kind of you know again
the developers design around that they
make these corridors not necessarily
because it adds to the story or the
experience of their you know artwork of
their game but because like it's
necessary so yeah let's make a corridor
here it can be helpful having a
30-second elevator ride is a little
extreme more realistically we'd probably
chop the world into a number of smaller
pieces and then do some calculations
with sightlines and runs beans like we
did for Haven City when we were making
jak 2 the game is 20 years old but not
much has changed since then all those
twisty passages are there for a reason
there's a whole subset of level design
dedicated to this sort of work yet still
it's a giant distraction for a team that
just wants to make their game it is and
the thing is like you're seeing the
industry like moving towards this kind
of like just works mentality and it's
that's really good obviously it's really
good when the person who says it just
works actually means it but the point is
that having to deal with limitations can
be not only disheartening and annoying
but it can really take the fun out of
making a game and when you're dealing
with a creative industry taking fun out
of thing
keeping people not at not in like a good
kind of happy positive attitude that can
hurt that resulting creativity and
that's that's a bad thing you can keep
your developers your artists everyone
happy because instead of again worrying
about how like how they're gonna add
another corner into this level because
like they just really can't they've
already added like five of them they're
sick of this they can't do this like
it's just not gonna it's gonna this is
gonna be ridiculous people gonna play my
game and be like why there's so many
corners but they have to because
otherwise it's not gonna work or they
just they can't well they have to reduce
the quality of their assets in their
game like that's very very very bad all
right my camera just overheated so
hopefully that happened again otherwise
we really will have to split up this
video anyway my point is if if
developers can just focus on making the
actual game and you know using their
creativity and the tools are not getting
in the way of the job that's just gonna
result in better games people people
miss this all the time people think that
oh why do they make this game like this
why didn't they make like you know
battlefield used to ship with 20 maps
now it ships with eight or battlefront
you just ship with like you know
battlefront true the original had like a
billion maps and so many playable
characters and now this battlefield has
like eight maps or four maps or whatever
it is Battlefront sorry people say these
things but they don't realize how much
harder it is to make content at this
quality bar not just because of the fact
that they have to spend more time
putting more details into their
environments into their characters
everywhere but because the hardware
net-like the hardware is also getting in
the way and being able to kind of put
that aside and make this really easy and
make everyone be able to express their
ideas in a super super good way that's
that is I think the single most
important part of this industry to make
tools and platforms that did not get in
the way of humans and their ideas and
their creativity so when I talked about
the dream of an SSD part of the reason
for that five gigabyte a second target
still recording eliminate loads but also
part of the reason for that target was
streaming as in what if the SSD is so
fast that as the player is turning
around
it's possible to load textures for
everything behind the player in that
split-second if you figure that it takes
half a second to turn that's four by the
way if that would possible that that
means that again you don't have to split
your world up into chunks you don't have
to worry about like oh I need this I
need that because every every single
asset like visual asset visual only
asset so like obviously if you still
need AI running in the background
colliding with things and pathfinding
and all of that you still need the basic
mesh for the world geometry and all that
loaded and you'll need other assets like
always for example present in RAM but
luckily those assets are generally a lot
smaller than really high detailed models
and textures and all that stuff so if
that were possible you wouldn't need to
worry about like corridors or even worry
about splitting up the world into
anything the world could literally be
pretty much infinite in complexity and
detail because it's only showing what
you're looking at and unless you can
look unless there's a section where you
can overlook the entire world and
everything has to be in like max detail
which it probably wouldn't because
certain things would be so far away that
you wouldn't really need to kind of
you'd have like some kind of proxy for
them like a lower LOD mesh or you know
some kind of you know with Unreal Engine
5 I guess some kind of you know triangle
culling thing that just figures out what
you actually need all of that stuff if
you can have that stuff like unless you
have that huge kind of overlooking thing
you know the actual like view of the
player usually is rather small and
that's that's really cool obviously if
you're dealing with like a level editor
where you're trying to design the world
and like you know the the developers are
using this tool to create this world and
they would want to see a lot of it at
once a lot more than the player usually
but gigabytes in general this is really
good that sounds about right
for next gen anyway back to the hard
drive another strategy for increasing
effective read speed is to make big
sequential chunks of data for example we
might group all the data together for
each city block that removes most of the
seeks and the streaming gets faster but
there's a downside to which is that
frequently used data is included in many
chunks and therefore is on the hard
drive many many times
marvel spiderman uses this strategy and
though it works very well for increasing
the streaming speed
there's a massive duplication as a
result some of the objects like
mailboxes or newsracks are on the hard
drive 400 times
Wow what I'm describing here are things
that cramp a creative director style
either level design gets a little bit
for it yes so again sometimes it's
necessary to have a duplication of
assets because they're part of a
different chunk and if you always have
them in one location on the hard drive
and you always have to again fetch from
everywhere it that can actually be a lot
slower than being able to say okay I
need all of this streamed in at once and
obviously that's resulting in
replication or the data is duplicated so
many times that it no longer fits on the
blu-ray disk and you end up with hard
limits on the players run speed or
driving speed the player can't go faster
than the load speed from the hard drive
yeah and finally I'm sure many of you
have noticed that after a patch download
the PlayStation 4 will sometimes take a
long time to install the patch that's
because when just part of a file has
been changed the new data can be
downloaded pretty quickly but before the
game boots up a brand new file has to be
constructed that includes the changed
portion otherwise every change would add
a seek or two even so you can
occasionally see this happening on game
titles they start to hitch once they get
patched enough with an SSS interesting I
haven't had too much experience with
like developing for consoles and all
that so I've never really noticed this
but this is really interesting
no seeks so no need to make brand new
files with the changes incorporated into
them which means no installs as you know
them today there's yet one more benefit
which is that system memory can be used
much more efficiently on PlayStation 4
game data on the hard drive feels very
distant and difficult to use by the time
you realize you need a piece of data
it's much too late to go out and load it
so system memory has to contain all of
the data that could be used in the next
30 seconds or so of gameplay that means
a lot of the 8ya because the the disk is
too slower Ram is obviously a lot faster
so you have to make sure that you don't
don't literally pause your game because
you're relying on disk load space bytes
of system memory is idle it's just
waiting there to be potentially used
on playstation 5 though the SST because
if you if the player suddenly makes a
sharp left turn and then you you just
need that asset then it better be in RAM
because if it's not then you know
prepare for like a second of just either
no textures on that model because
they're still being asynchronously
loaded or just like a pause see is very
close to being like more RAM typically
it's fast enough that when you realize
you need a piece of data you can just
load it from the SSD and use it there's
no need to have lots of data parked in
system memory waiting to potentially be
used mm-hmm a different way of saying
that is that most of Ram is working on
the game's behalf this is one of the
reasons that 16 gigabytes of gddr5 a
station 5 the presence of the SSD
reduces the need for a massive
intergenerational increase in size so
yeah but they don't need to have a
hundred and twenty eight gigabytes of
RAM or anything like that
because the SSD is so fast that they
just you know I'm actually it really
interested interested to see the
difference in speed between RAM and the
SSD I'm sure it's still it's still quite
large and obviously like this is a
different like architectural II speaking
it you know you need RAM because Ram is
what the CPU actually communicates with
the CPU does not immediately get data
from disk and then start processing it
it has to go through the RAM to actually
be you know so the safety instructions
actually do anything not to mention
that's where the CPU instructions are
there in the RAM but I'm still
interested I'm still interested to see
what the actual speed difference would
be between RAM and and SSD which again
like doesn't make too much sense because
the SSD speed is only going to be as
fast as the RAM speed because for the as
I just mentioned you know for the
daughter to get to the CPU has to go
through Ram anyway but I'm stood back to
the dream of the SSD here's the set of
targets with the game in a second no
load screens design freedom meaning no
twisty passages or long corridors more
game on the disk and more game on the
SSD yeah and the deduplication of game
daughter is relevant because of the of
the 0 is seek time that
finally those patch installs go away the
reality though is that the SSD is just
one piece of the puzzle there's a lot
surfaces where bottlenecks can occur in
between the SSD and the game code that
uses the data you can see this on
PlayStation 4 if I use an SSD with 10
times the speed of a standard hard drive
I probably see only double the loading
speed if that for PlayStation 5 our goal
was not just that the SSD itself be a
hundred times faster it was that game
loads and streaming would be a hundred
times faster so that's a hot that's a
hard goal to hear every single potential
bottleneck needed to be addressed and
there are a lot of them
let's look I'm I'm very impressed by the
way so far like I mean I haven't I don't
know the technical details of how they
achieved this and I don't know how real
it is obviously like I assume it's it's
accurate but what is saying so far like
this is a big technical achievement and
I think with that we'll probably pause
there for today's video hope you guys
enjoyed this little preliminary look at
the PlayStation 5 we're about 14 minutes
and 6 seconds in I'm not gonna watch any
of the video until the next time I sit
down and do this I'm actually gonna go
away do something else for a while and
let his daughter kind of process in my
brain and see if I'd come up with
anything else to say but I hope you guys
did enjoy this if you did please hit
that like button if you're new here then
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
as well please let me know what you
thought of this particular video and if
you think that I should do anything else
for the remainder of this video because
it is very long and obviously I have a
lot of thoughts to say if you're happy
with me to keep it kind of just putting
up chunks like this then obviously let
me know and I'll be fine thank you guys
for watching I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you